well understand that the New York Fed is
at the vortex of all the regulation that
is supposed to occur with respect to
banks the New York Fed is the least
known but most important regulatory body
out there it oversees all the financial
institutions controls access to
borrowing for these institutions and
actually has has individuals from the
New York Fed present at each of the
banks so it can see and hear and feel
what's going on in the marketplace and
yet it failed abject Lee to see what was
going on in terms of leverage in terms
of risk exposure etc now this is all
while Tim Geithner was president of the
New York Fed and Tim Geithner said when
he was being confirmed for Treasury
secretary he had never been a regulator
which should have been not just a flare
should have been an exploding missiles
saying this guy didn't understand his
job and I think he has failed as
Treasury Secretary's consequence put
that aside for a moment the AIG debacle
and the bailout of AIG were 180 billion
dollars of tax money was funneled
through a IJ much of it then being
passed through AIG to the counterparties
everybody from Goldman Sachs on down or
given a hundred cents on the dollar on
credit default swaps they had bought
from AIG for no apparent reason Goldman
was given a check for 12.9 billion
dollars which is parenthetically just
about precisely the profit they booked
last year calendar year 09 so the
entirety of Goldman's profit you can
think of as a tax payer infusion why did
we give that to them now Geithner and
blank fine would say because we were
owed it y know there's what possible
reason was there for taxpayers to give
Goldman Sachs that money I want to see
what their conversation was back and
forth would Goldman have failed absent
that infusion did we negotiate with
Goldman in return and get stock get
warrants did we negotiate the amount of
the payment why hundred cents on the
dollar all sorts of other people have
been taking huge financial hits why did
Goldman get paid off there are many many
areas of inquiry that would be
exposed and would be explained if we
could break through and see AI jeez
emails radiating out into the regulatory
and financial center
let me make it clear I don't think Tim
Geithner's a bad person by any stretch
of the imagination is he's not corrupt
he's not getting bags of cash he's he's
not morally in any way suspect he's
wrong and as I say there's no crime in
being wrong we were all wrong at one
point or another in varying degrees and
I'm certainly in that category as well
as everybody knows and so he was wrong
and so when I say he failed his Treasury
secretary it has failed as Treasury
secretary and is president of the New
York Fed it's because he did not bring
the right set of of principles and an
understanding of what his regulatory
role was supposed to be he embraced the
alan greenspan worldview of let them do
what they want because the marketplace
somehow will provide a magic answer and
that i think is the intellectual error
that he has committed along with larry
summers and again extraordinarily smart
brilliant individual but it's wrong and
you know there's no crime in being wrong
but i think that they have taken us to a
point in terms of economic policy that
is not good and we have all paid a price
in terms of the Cataclysm of the past
two years
understand that when the meltdown
occurred and so let's begin at the point
of the meltdown prior to the meltdown to
give you a quick answer on that leverage
was completely out of control there
should have been dramatic limitations in
a scale and back of leverage there
should have been a redefinition of what
banks that had access to the federal
window federal reserve window in terms
of tax gaining access to federal
guarantees in actual cash could do with
that money and that's prospectively as
well so retrospectively they failed to
control that the leverage and the risk
that was coursing through the system and
that's why we refer to it as systemic
risk prospectively the fundamental
reform we need and thankfully the
president has now begun to listen to
Paul Volcker much more than to tim
geithner Larry Summers on this we're
beginning to say to banks we will now no
longer permit you to ask taxpayers to
cover the down side while you keep the
upside knows the asymmetry between risk
and reward is what led to the massive
over leveraging and over exposure of the
system it's what we have called it
somebody else is lying not mine we've
socialized risk and privatized game and
any time I can play with a huge pile of
money and if I lose its your problem but
if I win I keep the upside of course I'm
going to get involved in much riskier
investments than I should and so we need
to correct that balance scale back the
leverage tell the banks do what banks
are supposed to do if you want access to
federal dollars to guaranteed deposits
lend that money to people who will
create jobs who will be businesses
borrowing to expand rather than using it
for either hedge funds private equity
investments proprietary trading the
sorts of endeavors that create great
risk through the system so that is one
structural issue which the president has
now begun to focus on whether it's post
Massachusetts and post political
meltdown or not doesn't really matter to
me he's now getting that right and I'm
hoping that Geithner and summers are
having their wings clipped because
they're the ones who were not
articulating for the president the
obligation to put that sort of reform in
place
you